when i was at school some of my teachers
used an overhead projector for lessons
you don't see them around very often
anymore in fact i was pretty surprised
that there is still available to buy in
some places
they were already going out of fashion
when i saw them back then and they're
quite a rarity now
but it's pretty cool how it works
there's a very bright bulb down in the
base which reflects light out onto the
surface
and then these light rays are focused
through a lens onto this mirror and then
reflected onto the wall behind me
and i can share any information i want
on here
by writing on these sort of plastic
transparencies
now i'm talking softly in this video
because i want this video to fall into
the category of asmr
now this is a genre of video that's
becoming quite popular and if you
haven't already encountered asmr videos
well they have a few intended purposes
one is to help people relax
another is to help people sleep and
everyone needs sleep and relaxation at
times so maybe that's why you can
understand it's quite popular
there's another thing that can happen
with asmr often when you're listening
with headphones in it can give you this
slightly tingly feeling in the back of
your brain
um and so that's why people like it too
often these asmr videos are really
softly whispered but i'm doing mine more
soft spoken one of the reasons for that
is this projector makes quite a lot of
noise there's a fan in the bottom to
keep everything cool
and i'm worried that if i whispered too
softly that perhaps you wouldn't be able
to hear me very well over the sound of
the overhead projector
i would like to quickly thank fabulous
for sponsoring this video fabulous is a
pretty fitting sponsor for this video
because they also place a lot of
importance on relaxation
mindfulness and self-improvement
fabulous is the number one self-care to
help you build better habits and achieve
your goals i think all of us have
experience with setting new year's
resolutions that get abandoned pretty
quickly
but the best way to actually achieve
your resolutions is to break them down
into tiny habits and the fabulous app
can help you stick to them it was
developed by behavioral scientists at
duke university and contains guided
journeys to help you achieve your goals
i've been using it to try and set up a
morning routine that gives me a bit of
momentum for the rest of the day
trifling can make all the difference
there's no shortcut to changing habits
but fabulous offers a sustainable
long-term approach to change your life
by building on small successes to start
building your ideal daily routine you
can click on my link in the description
and the first 100 people to do so will
get 25 of a fabulous subscription so
thank you to fabulous and let's get on
with the math
i have a plan for today to show you some
math questions using the overhead
projector and for it to be a relatively
relaxing sort of math lesson or overview
for some of you math might induce a lot
of anxiety
but hopefully this can be a way to boost
your confidence or interest just a
little bit
in you know quite a relaxing setting
i've got exam questions from brazil
turkey australia india the uk and the
usa
this video is going to be the opposite
of speed run i'm going to be going
through the problems quite slowly and in
a way that i can talk about some of the
fundamental ideas involved in the
questions so that
even if these things are quite
unfamiliar to you or it's been a while
since you did questions like these that
you will be able to follow along what's
happening and what some of those
fundamental ideas are behind it a reason
that i've picked exam questions to go
through is for me personally i've always
learned quite a lot from watching
problems get solved compared to you know
just reading about the fundamental ideas
seeing them actually in action and used
in a problem helps me understand their
context a lot better
our first stop is turkey this is a
question from the 2021 ayt exam
and like many of the questions that i've
chosen for this video it's for a kind of
an end of high school level or people
wanting to gain entrance into university
now
this question was translated and the
wording was quite long but essentially
it said that we've got two photographs
of the sunset now in photograph one the
sun appears as a semicircle this is the
ocean down here the sun and then the
clouds
now the distance from the top of the sun
to the water line is 3.9 centimeters as
measured on the photograph then after
some undefined time later we have
picture number two and the sun has sunk
a little bit down over the horizon
and now the distance from the top of the
sun to the water is only 0.3 centimeters
as measured on here
now what we want to find is this
question mark this mystery distance in
here which is how wide the sun appears
in our second photo a key word from the
question is that this first image of the
sun
is a semi circle and a semi-circle is
always exactly half of the circle
so that vertical distance that we're
given is indeed the radius so let's draw
our own semicircle
from here we can mark what we know if
the sun in the chili looks like this
then after some time
we just see the top of it the distance
in here was that given by 0.3
and this total distance we knew was 3.9
which means that if we'll take 0.3 off
that the rest is 3.6 our mystery
distance is this line all the way across
here but since we've cut it in half if
the whole thing were to be called x this
here would just be x over 2 and we can
actually draw a right angle triangle
right in here
since it's a semi-circle and this
distance was the radius
this line here is also the radius of the
circle so it is also 3.9
and with that we have a right angle
triangle where we know the value of two
of the sides and we're trying to find
the third side for that we're able to
use the pythagoras theorem
if this is our right angle triangle and
one of the shorter sides is a
the other shorter side is b
and the hypotenuse is c
then the pythagoras theorem says that a
squared plus b squared
is equal to c squared for us a is 3.6
our b is x over 2
and our c is 3.9
these decimal numbers are a little bit
messy but it's not impossible to
calculate these squares remember you
don't have a calculator for this
question we could go over to the margins
and write 3.6 times 3.6
we could do 6 times 6 is 36 carry the 3
3 times 6 is 18 19 20 21
add a zero here go on to the next line
three sixes are 18.
carry the 1 3 3's and 9 plus the 1 is 10
add these up we'll get 6
9
2 1
2 digits past the decimal place in here
so our decimal point will go between the
2 and the 9 and the answer to that would
be
12.96
again in our little margin we could do
the same to find 3.9 squared we'd go
three point nine times three point nine
nine times nine is eighty-one
three times nine is twenty-seven plus
eight will give us
thirty-five do our next line 3 times 9
is 27
3 times 3 is 9 10 11.
this one will add to give us
15.21
so we've got 12.96
plus
x over 2 squared is equal to 15.21
x over 2
squared is equal to subtract the 12.9
from both sides
to mentally find the difference between
these two numbers i'd say well this is
only
0.04 away from 13
and then 13 is
1
2.21 away from this so in total the
difference would be
2.25
x over 2 squared is the same as x
squared over 4
times both sides by 4 to get rid of this
we have x squared is equal to nine and
thankfully nine is a pretty easy number
to take the square root of so i'm going
to go with x is equal to three
centimeters
and so 3 will be the answer to this
length in here
i'm sorry to say but we actually did it
the slightly tedious way there was
something that we could have noticed
which would have made these calculations
redundant and the algebra a little bit
easier perhaps depending on how familiar
you are with pythagorean triples
pythagorean triples are known sets of
numbers that satisfy this a squared plus
b squared equals c squared
the smallest one is three four and five
let's take a look at a little bit of a
visual proof of fact
if i had a right angle triangle where
one side is of length three
and the other side is of length four
then the length of the remaining longest
side will be five squares
with the way that the light is projected
up onto my wall things up here look a
little bit larger than things down here
but believe me i've tried to make all
these individual squares the same size
each of these objects represents the
side length squared so 3 squared is this
square that's 1 2 3 by 1 2 3 a total of
9 little squares 4 squared is 16 so
there'll be 16 little squares here and 5
squared is 25
pythagoras's theorem is saying that the
size of this should be the same as the
size of these two added together
here's our 5 squared and i'm going to go
at it with my scissors
from this i can cut out a 4x4 grid
now i've got the 4x4
but let's see if this little remaining
bit can be made into a three by three
and there we go we can see our four
squared and our three squared popping
out of that five squared with nothing
left over
the next smallest pythagorean triple is
actually 5 12 and 13.
so when we were back at this stage there
is a chance that we could have noticed
that 36 is 3 times 12 and so 3.6 is 3
times 1.2
and 3.9 is 3 times 1.3
so following our pythagorean triple
x over 2 would have to be equal to
0.5
times three that's 1.5
so
x would be equal to well multiply by two
that's three centimeters
a faster way to get the same solution
that we had before
i don't know if you'll agree that it
simplifies the math by much but people
have been using pythagorean triples to
simplify their working for literally
thousands of years we've seen
pythagorean triples used on the world's
oldest example of applied geometry on a
3700 year old babylonian clay tablet
which laid out the division of land and
boundaries of a field and used
pythagorean triples like 5 12 and 13 a
thousand years before pythagoras himself
was even born so pythagoras wasn't the
first person to invent this or to find
these triples but the theorem still
holds his name our next stop is
australia now this is an exam question
from what is called the hsc advanced
paper and that is something that would
be set by high school students in the
australian state of new south wales
the question says
calculate the sum of the arithmetic
series
4
plus 10
plus 16
plus
dot dot plus one three five four
an arithmetic sequence is a sequence of
numbers in which there is a constant
difference between each term so you're
adding a constant amount every time
an arithmetic series is what it's called
when you add all of these terms together
in general if we called the first term
of our sequence a
then our second term would be a plus d
where d is our difference
and this one up here it looks like d
would be equal to six you've added six
here and then again here and so on
the third term of our sequence would be
a plus 2d
then all the way up to our last term
which would be a
plus
well how many times have we added d
if this is the nth term at the end and
we started adding d from the second term
onwards
then we would have added d
n minus one times
if you already know the formula to find
the sum of any arithmetic series then
you might be able to look at this and
plug it straight into that formula but
we're actually going to derive it so how
do you add up one of these things
well let's call the sum of our general
series here
s of n we're going to add up each term
starting with a
then
a plus d
then
a plus 2d
all the way to adding a plus n minus 1 d
now what we can do is write out the
series again but this time in reverse we
start with our last term a plus n minus
1d
and then our second to last term which
would be a plus n minus 2 d
then a plus n minus 3 d
and finishing with our first term a
you often see mathematicians try this
technique where they write out the
series again but backwards that's
because it allows them to do some kind
of cool tricks
one is to add these two series together
we add s of n to itself doing that we
would get two s of n's
the first term of that would be a
plus
a plus n minus one d well what is that a
plus a is
2a
plus
n minus 1
d
the next term is a plus d
plus
a plus n minus 2d
and that might look pretty different but
actually what do we have
an a here and an a here 2a
plus well we have n minus 2d
plus an extra d that's actually n minus
1 d
and in fact every term in here gives you
that same result i'm going to run out of
room on my transparency but a plus 2 d
plus a plus n minus three d
is also equal to two a plus n minus one
d
and you can see it pretty obviously with
our last term too
so in total we have that two
times s of n is equal to
this term
2a plus
n minus 1
d
repeated
for however many terms we have
so repeated
n times
to get rid of the 2 and get us the
expression just for one series
we can do n over 2 and we can simplify
it just a little bit more if we look
back to our sequence the last term is
always
a plus n minus 1d and we kind of see
most of that in here
although we have an extra a
and well a is always the first term so
this can also be written as n over 2
a which is the first term
plus the last term maybe we can call
that l
now that is the derivation of what will
always be the sum of an arithmetic
series
so let's get to working out our problem
we have what we've derived just here
and we know that well there's a constant
difference of 6 between each of our
terms
so d for us is going to be equal to six
our very first term a is equal to four
and our very last term
l is equal to
one three five four
we don't however know our value of n
they haven't told us how many terms
there are so we can't jump straight into
using this one instead let's put what we
know into this formula here for our last
term if one three five four is equal to
four
plus
n minus one
times six then subtracting the four and
dividing by six we have one 3 5 0
divided by 6 is equal to
n minus 1
that will be
2
2 5 i think you might be allowed a
calculator for this exam since the
australian one is equal to n minus one
and so n is one plus this
n is equal to two two six
now we have n and all that we need to
calculate the sum
so
s of n is equal to
2 6 over 2
the first term plus the last term
well if we plug all this into the
calculator we end up with 1
5
three
four
five four as our answer
well who would have guessed that's what
it is adding up all that this question
reminds me of a little story that goes
around about the mathematician carl
gauss he's known as perhaps one of the
greatest mathematicians and this is a
story from the time when he was at
school
apparently gauss's teacher wanted a bit
of peace and quiet so he asked the class
to add up all the numbers between one
and a hundred as the other students set
about adding it all up very slowly and
carefully
gauss almost immediately wrote down the
correct answer which was 5050
gauss could perhaps see a formula
similar to this one and applied it to
the problem he said to have imagined it
as folding up these numbers in half
and then adding up the pairs such as 1
and 100 and 2 and 99 that would be 50
pairs of 101 giving the answer or
expressed as a formula the first and
last term times n divided by two now
this anecdote tends to make the other
students in the class sound pretty
unintelligent as if they would add up
one plus two plus three and do every
single step in order but i challenge you
to imagine doing this for yourself even
if you knew nothing about math or
sequences and series and these formulas
and tricks as you go through the numbers
you can't help but see some patterns in
fact it almost seems difficult to do it
in the hardest way maybe you'd see that
in adding up the numbers between 10 and
19 you'd get the same sum as adding up
the numbers lower than that just with an
extra 10 sets of 10. so just because
you're not gauss answering it in a few
seconds doesn't mean there aren't lots
of ways to solve a problem like this
this next question is from india
now often when i've spoken about indian
exams on my channel before i've spoken
about things like the jee which is a
super specialized engineering focused
really difficult paper for university
entrance but this question here is from
the cbse
exams and in fact the standard
mathematics exam for grade 10. now this
isn't even the most advanced paper we
could have gone to grade 11 or 12 but i
found that picking the grade 10 one
brought it a little bit more in line
with some of the other problems i've
picked and made it a little bit easier
you know for this video where i don't
want to stress you out too much
um so the these cbse exam papers from
india are more standard sort of given to
everyone rather than just those people
who want to specialize in engineering
so let's have a look at the problem
it says
the value of k
for which the system of equations
x plus y minus four equals zero
and two x plus k y equals three
has no solution is
what
all right
equations like these represent straight
lines
and when we're talking about solutions
of systems of equations like this we can
imagine where the straight lines might
intersect
so if we have an x y axis like this
then in the case where for example one
line might go like this
the other might go like this
we have one place where the lines
intersect and that would represent one
solution
we also refer to this situation as being
consistent
let's try another possibility
if we have one line
and then another line exactly over the
top of it so that you can barely even
tell them apart well we're going to have
infinite solutions
because since these lines are perfectly
over the top of each other there are
infinitely many places where they meet
the situation is also referred to as
consistent
and there's one last possibility to
consider
and that is in the case where our two
lines
one here
and one here
are parallel to each other
they're like train tracks perfectly
parallel and they're never getting
closer or further away they're always
staying the same distance apart
in this case there will be no
solutions
the situation is referred to as
inconsistent
so in our question we're asked where
these two straight lines have no
solution
so really we're asked how we can ensure
that these lines will be parallel we
often see straight lines written in this
format y equals m
x plus c
this is the slope intercept format and
here m represents the slope of the line
and c represents the y-intercept so
where it cuts the y-axis
for two lines to be parallel they would
differ only in the y-intercept so they
would have the same gradient
but just shifted up or down by some
different amount c
if c was the same and the gradient was
the same well they'd be on top of each
other so one way to solve this is to
rearrange both these equations into this
form and see what you can do to make
sure that m is the same for both lines
but that c is different
but this is a question on an indian exam
and they love to find tricks where you
can solve these questions almost
instantly
sometimes that involves memorizing a lot
of seemingly random little formulas and
equations
to solve these quickly and maybe in the
extreme time pressure of exams like this
maybe even rearranging it into this form
is way too slow so let's see where a
shortcut might come from in general for
simultaneous equations in this form ax
plus b y is equal to c
often we can solve the equation by
adding these two together and hopefully
in a way that cancels out one of our
variables for example if a1 was 1 and a
2 was -1 then adding these two together
would remove the variable x and you
would be able to solve for y
if a1 and a2 or b1 and b2
aren't already the same magnitude we can
multiply them by some constant to make
sure that they are we just have to make
sure to multiply every term by that same
constant
for us our equations can be written as
x plus y is equal to four
and two x
plus k y is equal to three
if we multiply the entire top equation
by minus 2
then adding these together we would see
the x variables disappear
we would have minus 2x
minus 2y is equal to
minus eight
that's all fine because we did it to
every single term so it's the same
equation
adding these up we have zero x
then
k minus two y
being equal to minus 5. now we don't
know what k is but that's the thing
we're trying to find let's have a think
about it
if k was any value except for 2 this
would look like a normal equation we'd
have something times y is equal to -5 we
could find that y is equal to -5 divided
by whatever this value is that would
represent a consistent set of equations
one where there is one solution
but what if it gets weird what if k is
equal to two we'd have two minus two
that's zero
zero times y is still zero and we would
end up with
zero is equal to minus five that is if
k is equal to two
now believe it or not this is actually
what we want seeing something like zero
is equal to minus five well that is
inconsistent
there is no solution to this because
well think of it like this what values
of x and y
result in zero being equal to minus five
well
none there are no values of x and y that
ever make this true this is inconsistent
in the truest sense of the word so the
answer to the problem is actually k is
equal to two and if you're an indian
student studying for an exam
you probably already know a shortcut way
to think about this
it is to say that for no solutions
we want to ensure that the ratio a1 over
a2 that's these values here
we want to ensure that is equal to the
ratio of b1 over b2
basically means that when you decide to
multiply it by that constant minus 2
that we cancel both our x's and our y's
because these ratios are equal to each
other but we do not want both those to
be equal to the ratio of the constants
c1 over c2 that is the shortcut way to
find the answer to this problem so if
they have also been equal to c1 over c2
well in that case the constants would
have also cancelled out and we would
have been left with zero is equal to
zero that doesn't represent no solutions
in fact this is always true
zero is always equal to zero so if this
is the ratio between all the
coefficients you actually get infinite
solutions
now i also had questions prepared here
from the uk's gcse and from the american
sat exams
but i'm looking at my camera it's been
filming for a long time
looking at my mic it's about to run out
of batteries and i'm starting to feel
like maybe i've done enough already so
perhaps i'll save those extra two
questions for a part two or if anyone
enjoyed this video or made it to the end
let me know and i'll know to keep them
for later
thanks so much for watching this video i
know it's been a little bit different
it's been a little bit of a risk for me
to do
if you've been listening to try and fall
asleep then good night
and if you've been watching to relax or
unwind i hope that the rest of your day
is positive and not too stressful that
you get some good stuff done thanks as
always to my patreon supporters for
making my videos possible and a special
shout out to today's patreon cats of the
day who are very astronomically named
pan and tilt
you